Nó này, 2 tháng 7 năm, 8.5, thông tin từ công an tính vắc nền, đơn vị đã tạm sữa hình sự 2 đối tượng rằng
á quích, sinh năm, hình khu trong những bệnh và rằng ảnh, sinh năm, hình cùng chú tại sát sơ lương, tính lâu cai để đều trà hình vi hức giống trẻ mề sấu tụi.
Trước đó, khoảng 18,5 năm, ngày 1 tháng 7 năm, 8.5 năm, 8.5 năm, em nờ mề sấu tụi, ở sát nà sòn.
Tình định niên được hai đổi tự trẻ dù đi ăn uống cùng một số người bạn mới quên tại một quan việng ở khu tên sát, phương hạp lính, tính bắc nền.
Tại đây, quý vàiến đã bản bản thống nhất với nhau về việc app nở uống xe để thực hiện quan hệ tình dục trai i muốn.
Lời dụi việc nở bị xe dự, khoảng 18,5 năm, quý vàiến đã trở nở đến khu vực lũ dù.
Tụi địa phần khu xin năm, phương nà sơn, tính bắc nền, nơi không quán người xí xống, khoa lại để thực hiện hình vi hức giống.
Sau khi sự việc dính ra, châu tối cùng ngày nơi được người xin để phương phát hiện đưa đến công an phương nằm sơn để chính báo sự việc.
Công an phương nằm sơn đã chuyển vụ việc lên các quan cải sát đưa trẻ công an tính bắc nền, để đưa trẻ thạp thẩm quyền.
Hình cơ quan cải sát đưa trẻ công an tính bắc nền đang tích tục đưa trẻ làm só hủ an để sư liên nghiên theo quy định của pháp lật.